good news for lazy joggers that makes no
sense
scientists develop ankle exoskeleton
that makes running 14% easier than in
normal sports shoes so apparently huh
Nike shoes funded this at this research
and they developed some kind of EXO
Ironman type what look at this eye
begins its it begin this is the the
start so here's here's thing this is
what here's the thing I want to run
faster let me tell you the thing here's
the thing another beanie is what makes
Iron Man Tony Stark a superhero is that
he as one person developed all of these
things very very quickly right we in
real in a cave in it well no no he made
a weird bombs the first Ironman I know
right he did but he like a crappy said
he went home and he was like yeah yeah
so what do we have right now we got a
guy who can fly yeah and now we got a
guy who can run oh we got to bring these
things together mm-hmm and then we're
gonna have the real suit but let's let's
be honest like if you wore an Ironman
suit and and someone hit you with like a
mortar shell you're gonna die like I
don't know what as suits made of like
mad cuz I thought there's that scene in
the first one where he's flying in the
tank fires they artillery shell and
every Iron Man he gets shot against the
wall and it's just like boom I'm okay
that's right I'm okay it's like well
what about your brain your brains your
insides liquid fluid and if it hits the
back you're gonna get a concussion I
just assumed that Iron Man has some kind
of maglev like force field that absorb
force dampening a tomato inertial
dampeners yeah like a Star Trek
yeah the inertial dampeners so check us
out how the ankle exoskeleton works now
it's just the ankle so this story is a
is kind of a letdown but it's still
pretty cool we can run better I actually
bought these things I got there they
were advertised at me on Instagram okay
they're these spring-loaded knee braces
oh man I've seen those they don't work
yeah I heard that they didn't work
because it's it creates a weird
obstruction in your knee when you bend
them yeah and it just feels weird
it actually doesn't it feels worse but
the idea is interesting so there are
these things that you strap them onto
your knees and in the back there's a
spring and it's like plastic and then
when it bends it resists all I can think
is that your Instagram sucker
yeah I buy so much stuff off Instagram
to get idea look at that UFO thing yeah
here look switch to us that UFO I saw on
Instagram you took a long time to get
here - it's pretty cool we forgot about
it and turned up and we were like oh my
goodness it's a lamp I gotta be honest
though I like the globe better oh no I
like the FO but hey we you know we
should we should have a vote look at it
it's obviously there's two against one
but not I'm talking about you guys out
there what do you think she's the globe
or the UFO shout out in the commas at me
at me in the comments if you want the
globe and then a thing if you uh look at
that you like the UFO that is cool it's
floating yes
meaning yes it can play music yeah I
read it this hangar and it's charging
while it's floating that's awesome I'm
not saying it's not cool
anyway back to the to the exoskeletons
so let's see they say couch potatoes
trying to get in shape could one day be
helped along their fitness journey by an
ankle exoskeleton that makes it easier
and less tiring to run okay I'm gonna
stop you right there if you don't like
running don't do it it's not gonna make
you run what listen that's what I was
thinking you've got to develop good
habits
no one's gonna run with these if they
don't like running if you don't like
running you're not gonna run yeah you
know I like skateboarding I actually do
like running cuz there is a point where
you kind of get the endorphins run in
and yet you go into like this spacey
cloud space and it's actually pretty
late
I like freerunning but I do like skating
over over running well so here's I'm
gonna always go skate instead doing
something you don't want to do is very
difficult okay and you need community
support to get into something so like
you're somebody who wants if you're
create a lazy couch potato and you want
to get into running find some people to
run with and and and hang out with them
and you need to build that community for
me I skateboarding is a very solitary
thing I skate cause I want to yeah some
people skate cause I wanna be with their
friends but when I go out I'm not like
time to exercise we're gonna go see a no
it's like I want to skate I just happen
to be getting exercise so what what are
the real benefits of this exoskeleton
and
no military capabilities you know you
don't think so I don't think so not for
because percent energy but the military
is gonna use robots they're not leaning
to make humans go out there with like
super suits to run faster this is just
someone who you know is coming up with
something that's you know it is kind of
cool but what's the application to this
it's not going to be the military the
military wants robots they don't want to
lose humans that's why they're studying
gamers brains they're studying people
who control like Starcraft kind of like
you know them sending masses and
understanding the flow of battle to do
robots not also super humans I'm
actually it's not happening I'm actually
a bit bummed apparently these tethers
are like mounted to motors that go into
your suit
yeah sure this is you know this is the
start right so maybe they wear a
backpack at some point but the other
thing is what they're arguing like
they're saying you know eventually a
version will be created help runners on
a treadmill save an average of 24
percent more energy I thought the goal
over one minute I thought the goal of
running on a treadmill was to burn
energy yeah exactly what what is the
point of this what this feels like
wasted research no no I think so what's
the point of this is the reason if we
can if we can make simple exosuits to
increase there was one guy he's got one
it's a hydraulic suit ok and he was able
to lift ridiculously heavy things with
it interesting so so so that makes sense
to me yeah so like it has some
applications outside just simply it's
like hydraulic bars with like a hook at
the end and he would like hook it around
stuff and then lift like you know 100
200 pound weights nope right well this
makes it so you can run you and save
energy when you run where you running
what maybe you got a job and you got a
run
maybe you're oh yeah maybe your job
what's who's the guy who ran the
marathon that you know they're gonna
allow this in a marathon oh yeah exactly
that guy what what's the origin of the
marathon who did it the marathon
originated because some dude had to run
26 miles or something in like ancient
Rome no and then he like ran as fast he
could to deliver this message
one of the gods had the wings on his
feet was that him
that's mercury yeah Hermes but that's
like the story of the marathon or
whatever no idea what's it like but
let's look there are people who have to
run in certain environments why the
right right now we don't have Boston
Dynamics tile robots to go to fight yeah
you know what the people who are in
civilizations that need to run are super
fit their muscles are used to running
and they're they're like they were like
oh yeah running the store like it would
take more time for me to be strapped up
in this stuff to then go there I could
just run and get there and get the thing
and come back before you're even you're
like halfway there even though you run
faster you still gotta I don't know just
like say it's it's we're talking about
this is this is like Ironman stuff it's
like level level one we're just getting
started baby I know I I agree I just
what if I want to see you ever see some
real applications you ever see Mario
Brothers the movie yeah man when they
put those things on their legs make him
jump really high
yeah that wouldn't work but what if it
could I mean it's the same thing we
talked about earlier you fly up real
high and you fall and die right so but
here's the idea though the idea is that
you have these things on your legs okay
that have stored energy and like a
spring or some kind of you know I don't
piston have no do sure and right when
you jump it release at the same time
giving you an extended jump when you
land it absorbs energy and compresses it
backs down it clicks in sure okay but if
you mess up if you mess up you'll be
flipping and going like hitting somebody
run into something but hey man look
that's a mess I've seen I've seen
football players just running and they
tear their ACL and I've also seen the
stupidity of humans very prevalent as of
late and people will have access to this
kind of thing and we like bouncing
around you know I don't want to see that
I do know the story of spring-heeled
Yanks what is the spring-heeled jack
spring-heeled Jack no I don't yes
spring-heeled jack is an entity and
English folklore of the Victorian era
the first claim sighting of
spring-heeled the Jack was in 1837 there
many theories about the nature of an
identity of spring-heeled Jack the urban
legend was very popular in his time
due to the tales of his bizarre
appearance and ability to make
extraordinary leaps to the point that he
became the topic of several works of
fiction
spring-heeled Jack was described at
people who claimed to have seen him as
having a terrifying and frightful
appearance with diabolical physio
physiognomies clawed hands and eyes that
resembled red balls of fire one report
claimed that beneath a black cloak he
wore a helmet and a tight-fitting white
garment like an oilskin many stories
also mentioned a devil like aspect
others said he was tall and thin with
the appearance of a gentleman several
reports mentioned that he could breathe
out blue and white flames okay this is
just getting absurd
yeah wasn't OPM really heavy mass
hysteria put it right there
yeah so my general understanding of why
they call him spring-heeled jack was
that the assumption was he had some kind
of things in his boots and he could jump
really high yeah and there were stories
that like they would be being chased and
then he'd just jump on top of a building
have you ever seen what's that movie for
a Brothers Grimm I think it is no I
think it's Heath Ledger and Matt Damon
yeah and they just like they're the
grimm brothers who like yeah kill the
demons or whatever and it's it's all a
hoax they got like springboard set up oh
yeah Vince the people that there are
things but it's all just like smoke and
mirrors it's like that's that's that's
the reality of ninjas you know that is
it so I know that that's cool I'm not a
ninja expert but I have read one or two
reddit articles when they popped up and
I was reading how they would try to
create the perception of having magic
powers okay - so people would avoid
fighting them so one of the things they
would do is before like they're
assassins right yeah they wouldn't dress
in all black that's that's like that's
from like theater they would wear
regular clothes of regular people so
they could blend in makes sense but
let's say there was like a building and
they had to assassinate somebody okay
they would prepare for the escape so in
the pond in the lake next to it they
would put wooden like wooden beams and
then after they assassinate their target
and were fleeing and being chased and
you run across the lid they would run a
cloth across the lake and people
and be like mmm demons yeah when they
were really just jumping from log to log
yeah yeah so it was all about trickery
and deception well not always but that's
one of the things they would do you
create you know so maybe this spring
he'll Jack I was just some some dude who
preset maybe it was a board in the
ground the spring yeah and he would run
and hit it and they would bounce him in
the air and they've got how did he do
that not realize he's right bring healed
yeah but I dig I dig the old urban
legend yeah he's like jumping around and
look at things like what he's like the
original Batman he's high yeah for real
look at this guy's very cool he looks
kind of flamboyant it is it's literally
the Batman and the Joker together look
at his smile it kind of does I know I
got these scars yeah my boots
I jumped really high and fell down onto
a fence post right my right is Melbourne
well anyway I don't know you have any
final thoughts on the the coming oh
that's the wrong story you have any
final thoughts on the coming I don't
know all I can think is exoskeleton
beanies are coming soon there we go I
just I'm still still don't buy spring
heels don't buy exoskeleton suits by
beating prepare beanies for all
collection beanies for some have you
wanted to become a beanie bro well soon
you'll have no chance
IRL beanie coming to you soon soon yes
yes and these are gonna be like made in
America made in America and packaged by
regular himself yeah Jesus I'll even
sign them for you yeah maybe I know we
should put like little cards into and
stuff like that and like yeah they get a
little package some comments you know
you know we should do a gardener no we
should make uh we should make like gag
Magic cards
okay and the beatings can come with
magic arts oh my the game like you know
right maybe we should make canceled
culture cards uh well I mean I guess we
can kind of let people know we're
working on it every knows working on it
oh they do yeah oh I've talked about a
lot yeah on the show oh [ __ ] we're
working on the card game it's called
cancel culture yet we're working on a
game and the the goal of the it's a card
game it's it's going to be simplified
we're
we're trying to work out ways to stop it
from becoming a rich person's game like
a lot of games even Pokemon magic cards
become ridiculously expensive
we're get rid of all that we want a game
where you can pop up in the box and you
can play with your friends and it's
really funny because the goal of the
game is that you are trying to cancel
your opponent yep so it's a baby so it's
it's good it's it's basically just a
bunch of pop-culture references and it's
the the gag is you know you'll you'll
have a character who's like Peter Jordan
s'en fighting against you know ro
Geoghan or wet brine Stein I mean
there's a really really poorly
thought-out Gagne's but we're working on
like making a very silly parody everyone
will get torn apart no one is safe I
will say toilet girl is a thing toilet
girl well and and and that's the goal
for the expansions is to actually just
make like the like when when stories
come out there's viral moments will make
Moe make cards for these things yeah and
but you know yeah yeah so I'll put I
want to say one thing about it
we're gonna make fun of everybody oh
yeah we're to make fun of me we're gonna
make fun of feminists everyone will get
torn apart no one will be spared but of
course I guarantee you one side of this
is going to laugh at all the mockery and
the other side is gonna say it's bigotry
and it's sexist and it's you know all
the awful things all right or whatever
whatever we're channeling our energy or
carlin I also want to design a chess set
a culture war chess set okay where the
pawns on one side are a bunch of like
fat neckbeard with katanas and like
fedoras and dusters and then the pawns
on the other side are big fat mohawk
feminists and like just make like a
chessboard for the culture world be
funny I'll leave it to you but we are
working on a card game it's gonna be
really fun yeah to simplify what we're
trying to do is it's just gonna be pop
culture so it'll be really funny to have
Kathy Griffin you know trying to get Joe
Rogan banned from the internet you're
going at it and like you know things
like that just silliness parody making
fun of people making fun of this whole
this whole culture war stuff yeah we're
working on it now it's coming so uh well
we'll see how long it takes you know we
we do a lot of things but maybe maybe
soon thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
toons and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you